attention humans shape-shifting alien
lizards have taken control of your world
they've maneuvered themselves into
positions of power and they could be
anyone
where did these powerful reptilians come
from
how could you tell if someone is a
lizard in disguise
and how could you possibly defeat these
all-powerful overlords
this is what if and here's what would
happen if lizard people ruled the world
you know almost 13 million Americans
believe the conspiracy theory that the
United States government is run by a
secret race of aliens
yeah
and for many Believers the control this
group has goes far beyond the U.S
they control the whole world
yeah so supporters of this Theory claim
that these creatures have been among us
since ancient times
many famous world leaders belong to
their cold-blooded race such as Queen
Elizabeth and former U.S President
George W bush
oh and secret societies like the
Freemasons and the Illuminati are run by
these lizards too
this belief in secret reptilian
overlords dates as far back as 1888.
more recently it's been widely
popularized by one conspiracy theorist
who's also faced accusations of
anti-semitism
so is the belief in Alien overlords a
myth with dangerous consequences
or maybe just maybe totally real
I am not a lizard
to prepare yourself to properly identify
the aliens among you you should
familiarize yourself with their
background here's what you need to know
the reptilians wouldn't originate from
Earth they'd come from distant solar
systems around the Orion and Draco
constellations
after arriving on Earth they would
interbreed with humans
they'd even managed to manipulate our
DNA to cover up the truth
but these human reptile crosses would
only be temporary leaders they'd be
holding power until their original
reptilian ancestors returned to Earth
and they would rule by fear creating
anxiety amongst people like you so that
you'd more easily Embrace an
authoritarian One World Government
but luckily for you these reptilians
would be easy to spot once you know what
to look for
the first sign is chameleon eyes or eyes
that change color of course that might
be too tricky to pull off due to lizard
people having excellent Vision so you
should approach people with caution who
have blue green or hazel eyes wait I
have hazel eyes
next beware of hair specifically people
with red locks or even slightly reddish
this could be a Surefire sign that
someone is really a lizard
other signs that could cast doubt if a
person is of lizard origin is if they
have suspiciously good hearing the
capability of disrupting electrical
appliances and of course known contacts
with aliens
now you could be running through a long
list of all the people you've ever
encountered who fit these most unhuman
of descriptors
maybe looking at videos on your phone of
one of your best friends could reveal
how suddenly weird they appear from one
frame to the next
that's right they could be a lizard
Overlord if only you could see their
true nature the scaly skin the yellow
eyes the cleft tongue but the list of
potential lizard traits runs even longer
this list even includes a love of Space
and Science
yeah the most revealing and dangerous
indicator of all
but wait a minute there's someone else
who loves Space and Science you
so just about everyone you know yourself
included could be among a lizard race
controlling the planet
what could you possibly do to stop them
well how about this lizards love dark
cool places you could start by moving
out of your parents basement and into a
bright clean apartment
they also love water so next time
someone offers you a trip to the pool or
the beach
uh you should probably skip it if all
else fails you could repel the lizards
in your life by creating your own
cologne or perfume try something that's
heavy on the hot sauce and pepper that
should do the trick
maybe what you should really do is take
your head out of the rabbit hole of this
conspiracy theory it could seem like fun
and games but beliefs in these theories
can really start to warp your
perspective on the reality around you
besides what if the aliens aren't
actually ruling the Earth but rather
living inside of it
well that's a story for another what if
[Music]